Facebook had a really difficult year in
2019 I think there was a lot of
criticism coming from basically everyone
from users regulators and even a couple
of Facebook executives so one of the
first big moments of the year for
Facebook was when the FTC imposed a five
billion dollar fine on the company this
was the largest in the history of the
FTC and it was something that people
were watching really closely because it
was the first major slap on the wrist
for this company in the u.s. not
everyone was happy with the way that
this turned out because five billion
dollars actually represents a small
fraction of Facebook's annual income I
think in that quarter alone Facebook
generated about 15 billion dollars this
was something that the company had
planned for it basically impacted the
stock very little also in July other
regulators started looking at Facebook's
business practices and so in addition to
the FTC looking at how Facebook
mishandled the user information you also
had the Justice Department looking at
Facebook's business practices and trying
to determine whether they were
anti-competitive Facebook critics have
said that the number of acquisitions
that Facebook has encouraged you know
companies like Instagram and whatsapp
and all of the other large acquisitions
that this company had taken on in the
past few years were actually
anti-competitive because these were
defensive maneuvers to ensure that
Facebook would continue to control what
a lot of people call the attention
economy so as long as people are logging
on to Facebook products they can
continue to serve ads to those people
this is all about capturing users
attention and making sure that they're
interacting with Facebook products for
as long as possible throughout the day
Facebook announced plans to launch its
own cryptocurrency which was met with a
torrent of criticism mainly because
people are having issues trusting
facebook although this came under a lot
of criticism mark zuckerberg went to
washington to defend this idea he
believes that it's going to give a keen
access to the 14 million people in the
US who are unbanked right now they don't
have a checking or savings account and
this would essentially allow them to to
create one what's funny is that when he
showed up in Washington he was hit with
this with a number of questions that
were completely unrelated to Libra there
were a lot of antitrust questions there
were questions about political
advertising and there were questions
about house
soon Mark Zuckerberg was aware of the
camera channel it Iike data leak while
Twitter and Google have taken hard
stances against false claims made in on
political advertising and in twitter has
completely banned political advertising
on its platform Facebook staunchly
fought for the right for candidates to
advertise on its side form Facebook CEO
Mark Zuckerberg has said that he doesn't
want the company to fact-check political
ads you know this raises the question
whether readers have the ability to even
determine whether these claims are true
or false in let's say like a 15-second
video ad already there has been 60
million dollars spent on political
advertising leading up to the next
year's election the importance of this
is going to continue to increase as we
head into 2020 and it's something that
Facebook will have to grapple with as we
near the election the company has said
that it will continue to consider how it
handles political advertising the year
started off on a pretty rocky note I
think since the last election people
have been looking at Facebook a lot more
critically I think people are less
trustworthy of what they read on
Facebook I think they're less
trustworthy of the company and yet the
stock continues to perform well the
company is up more than 50 percent I
believe it was up as high as 56% earlier
this year Facebook continues to launch
new products they continue to inject
themselves into our everyday lives and
so although the news cycle started on a
bad note and basically that note
continued throughout most of the year
Facebook stock and the enthusiasm from
investors has not waned
you